okay if you have a favorite twitch
streamer odds are you've sub to their
channel at some point you give them five
bucks to show support and maybe they
shout you out on stream as a thank you
they get paid you get cool emotes
everybody wins but what if you're a
streamer
and twitch recently decided that
thousands of your subs are fake
and that they won't be paying you out
the twenty thousand dollars you believed
you're owed
and there's nothing you can do about it
that's exactly what's happening to one
rainbow six seed streamer by the name of
varsity gaming
[Music]
all right guys before we get into the
story if you like content about twitch
and streaming
make sure to subscribe to the channel
like the video and leave a comment below
we read a lot of these comments and
believe it or not they're actually
helpful for deciding what content we
make
alright back to this story varsity
gaming is a popular rainbow six siege
youtuber who started streaming on twitch
back in 2017.
elevator
he recently tweeted out that twitch owes
him ten thousand dollars in revenue for
subs for the month of march
but twitch says those subs are fake and
they won't be paying him the money
so i reached out to talk to him about
this situation and it turns out that
this has happened
three separate times and he believes in
total that twitch owes him roughly 20
grand
some months have been fine other months
have been like
payments missing by like 5k like i told
you september december and then
10k for march and um i've contacted
twitch multiple times and haven't told
or they haven't told me anything
now obviously there's a few different
ways streamers make money subscriptions
bits donations sponsorships and if
you're popular enough an exclusive
contract with the platform worth
millions like these guys
thanks and i'll see you at twitch.tv dr
lupo
subs act as an incentive for both
streamers and viewers if you're a
streamer you're trying to put out good
content and maybe you have some perks on
the side
so hopefully people buy into what you're
making and if you're a viewer
you show your support by paying that
five dollars and subbing to the channel
and sometimes the community itself grows
and becomes a reason to sub
now in most cases twitch splits a sub 50
50.
so even when you fork over that five
dollars your favorite streamer is only
seeing a percentage of that
so with all that in mind if you're not
dr disrespect pokeman or tim the tatman
who have all signed exclusive
multi-million dollar contracts with the
platform
subscriptions are a vital way for small
and medium streamers to make a living
so if you have a small but loyal
community that subscribe to you every
month
that's a huge deal because it means that
it gives you an opportunity
to make streaming your job okay so how
does all of this apply to varsity
gaming's situation
well the first problem he ran into was
in september of 2019 when he says that
twitch underpaid him by almost
five thousand dollars after they flagged
a bunch of his subs as fraudulent now
varsity gaming has a theory
as to why twitch flagged all of these
subs for the month of september
and it has to do with an in-game item
from rainbow six siege
before that i had about an average of
fifteen hundred to two thousand subs per
month
uh so like kind of a medium-sized small
channel and then my charm came out in
rainbow six siege which like
blew up my subscriptions because all the
people from youtube where i have like
900k
subs now came over to twitch to sub to
get the charm
so yeah according to him he saw a giant
spike in his sub numbers due to the
release of his streamer charm
and he believes that twitch saw all of
these people coming to his channel to
subscribe and get the streamer charm
as unusual which is why they flagged all
these subs
not that the subs were actually
fraudulent or fake
the same thing happened in december for
another five grand and he's not sure
what happened there
but then again for a third time this
happened in march
this time for ten thousand dollars or
the big reason why i saw like such a
huge explosion in subs is because the
twitch prime skin
came out for the mozzie uniform and
that like i have never received so many
subs in such a short time not even when
i got my charm like this
blew it up even more it was a really
popular skin
and then so i went from i think i had
like five k or six k subs to 11k
in two weeks and um i'm assuming that's
probably
what like made them suspicious because i
had a lot of people subbing saying i'm
only here just for the mozzie skin
because i advertised it in a video
saying if you want the skin you can go
to twitch and claim it with twitch prime
and then if you're there you might as
well
sub to me if you want gotcha and it
brought over a lot of people
but didn't like really change my
viewership so again he believes that
everybody coming over to claim that
twitch
prime mozzie skin is what twitch saw as
weird so they flagged those subs
not that those subs were fraudulent or
fake and when he reached out to twitch
about what was going on he got emails
back saying that the subs have been
flagged
investigated and reported as fraudulent
which basically means that twitch is not
going to pay him any of the money he
believes he's owed and then he says when
he asked twitch to further explain what
was happening
each ticket for the issue that he raised
was closed which to him
says that twitch didn't really feel like
talking about this anymore
okay but how are subs considered fake or
fraudulent
well that's the thing in this specific
situation
varsity gaming was never told how well
according to twitch's terms of service
money deemed fraudulent is quote not
subject to payout but that's about all
the tos says about this issue there's
different sections in the community
guidelines about view botting
and like sub for sub type schemes but
that's about it there's nothing that
talks about what an investigation looks
like
what type of response a streamer can
expect or how twitch sees these subs as
faker
and varsity gaming says every time he's
tried to bring this issue up with twitch
he's just referred to the tos
now whether or not you're a small or
well-known streamer if you don't know
how much money you're going to be
bringing in
each month that puts you in a difficult
situation when you're trying to plan for
the future
which is exactly what varsity gaming
told me he's going through right now
at the end of the day obviously like i'm
grateful for everything with
all the subs i have but when i see like
20
of my subs just going away and i'm
trying to make plans with my money like
we're trying to get a house and trying
to organize my finances around that and
now something like my
monthly income is dropping by 10 or so
thousand
that's pretty significant for me and
makes my life a lot harder to plan
now this type of vague language and lack
of clarity about how twitch operates is
something that people have been upset
about for a while now
whether it's the nudity policy which
twitch just updated or the inconsistent
messaging around
bands people are often confused about
how twitch disciplines as streamers
and because of this lack of clarity and
confusion about how twitch operates
we don't actually understand if these
subs are fraudulent or if they're
actually coming from people subbing to
his channel for the streamer charm
and the mozzie skin and neither does
varsity gaming he has no idea
this isn't the first time twitch has
come under fire for investigating what
they believe to be fraudulent
subscriptions
back in 2019 streamer craig williams was
banned indefinitely from the platform
after twitch saw that he had 1300 subs
but he only streamed once a week
instead of asking craig about the
discrepancy they banned him from the
platform because they basically believed
he was inflating his sub numbers
but after craig told twitch that yes i
only stream once a week
but people sub to my channel because
they get access to my online shop
where i help them build sim racing
setups well twitch apologized and
actually reversed the ban
so you can see how these two situations
are similar twitch has grown fast in the
last couple of years and while streaming
started out as a hobby people do on the
side
it's turned into a legitimate career for
a lot of streamers and the problem here
is you wake up every day to do your
full-time job
and the messaging around how you're
going to get paid is inconsistent
now if you're twitch this is obviously a
complicated situation
on the one hand you don't want streamers
inflating their numbers and basically
scamming you for revenue
but on the other it's hard to tell the
difference between
a bot account and a relatively harmless
account just trying to subscribe to
their favorite channel now
varsity gaming says he still hasn't
heard back from twitch about the
payments for march
and while he's a relatively popular
youtuber with almost a million
subscribers
twenty thousand dollars to him is still
a gigantic amount of money
just with any kind of new game trying to
memorize the keybinds and stuff so
i'll like i'll often hit uh q for some
ability when i meant to hit e
and then like it does the wrong thing
and i die and then because it's me i get
so [ __ ] angry um i've smashed my desk
a couple times and i've yelled
and my desk is like the hallway to my
front door is just kind of off my
my uh desk area so i guarantee you
people can hear me in the hallway just
being like [ __ ]
yeah honestly like i don't really give a
[ __ ] what they think
but yeah it's probably annoying